TO MEET --
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM BUT I WOULD
LIKE.
TO WAIT JUST A COUPLE MORE
MINUTES IF WE GET.
FULL COMPLEMENT OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP FOR OUR FIRST MEETING --
SO IF YOU ARE A MEMBER OF OUR
COMMITTEE I WILL CALL AT ANY
NAMES.
WE ARE SET AT NINE AM TODAY AND
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE COME TO THE
DESIGNATED ROOM ONE TWELVE FOR
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BEGIN AND
CONCLUDE IN TIMELY FASHION SO.
QUICKLY JUST A COUPLE MORE
MINUTES FOR THE REST OF OUR
COMMITTEE WE WILL PROCEED AT
THAT POINT --
CAN FILL IN THE SAUCE G.
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WELL
[inaudible]
IRAQ.
IN OUR OWN HOUSE [inaudible]
THIS IS.
SHE'S GOING --
TO IT HAS A SMALL [inaudible]
ORIGINAL [inaudible]
PRESIDENT BUSH --
THIS.
IS.
LONG [inaudible]
AND GOOD [inaudible]
THERE -- THE
SHARED.
BACK.
OVER.
HERE -- SO
THE SAY.
YOUR THOSE ARE.
BOTH OF YOU --
FOR THAT --
RUMORS.
STARTED SEEING THE YEAH RAKOFF.
ERRORS SHOWS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT ABOUT?
THE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE.
YEAH.
THIS IS.
I HAVE AROUND [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE ARE ALMOST AT FULL COMPLEMENT
TO AND WE WILL PROCEED AND IF
SENATOR STRN COULD FIND HIS WAY
DOWN HERE WE WILL HAVE A
COMPLETE --
COMPLEMENT OF MEMBERS SO GOOD
MORNING --
WELCOME TO THE FIRST COMMITTEE
HEARING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON THE JUDICIARY.
CALL THIS MEETING TO ORDER --
AND PART OF THE REASON I WANTED
TO HAVE EVERYONE HERE IS THAT WE
WILL BE SAYING.
FAREWELL TO OUR REPUBLICAN STAFF
MEMBER OF MICHAEL AFTER EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF BEING THE MINORITY.
BUT I DON'T KNOW EITHER MINORITY --
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AID OR EVERYBODY ASKS FOR SMALL
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY ALWAYS IN
THE MINORITY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE BUT LET'S JUST SAY.
THAT --
MICHAEL PETERSON HAS BEEN A
GENTLEMAN --
IT HAS DONE AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB
ON BEHALF OF HIS MEMBERS AND IS.
GOING TO BE RETIRING AFTER THIS
OF A MEETING TODAY AND SO I
WANTED TO ALL OF US TO EXTEND
OUR CONGRATULATIONS.
AND APPRECIATION.
SO WITH THAT WE DO HAVE SOME NEW
MEMBERS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME BACK SENATOR MOANING AND
SENATOR STERN'S SEAT.
AND SENATOR WHY KOWSKI AND OF
COURSE A WARM WELCOME TO OUR NEW
MEMBERS ARE NEW VICE CHAIR
SENATOR BORCHERS AND WELCOME --
TO SENATOR ALAN SENATOR CUBBY AT
ALL AND SENATOR UMBERG WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU AND THIS
IS A VERY.
INTERESTING COMMITTEE WE HEAR
ALL KINDS OF ISSUES --
FROM THE LANDS OF COURSE OF THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE --
I THINK WE HEAR MORE BILLS --
AS A IS NOT NECESSARILY THE THE
FIRST GO ROUND BUT IS THE SECOND
OR THIRD COMMITTEE --
THAN ANY OTHER COMMITTEE HITS A
LOT OF WORK --
AND HOPEFULLY YOU'LL ENJOY THE
EXPERIENCE A LAWYERS ON THE THE
TEAM NOW  THINK --
IT REALLY WILL ADD TO THE
DISCUSSION.
OF THE HOURLY PAID THE HOURLY
RATE IS FAR LESS THAN WHAT YOU
COULD MAKE PRACTICING LAW BUT
IT'S THE POLICY THAT COUNTS SO --
TODAY WE NEED TO START UP BY
APPROVING THE RULES OF OUR
COMMITTEE THEN WE'LL CONSIDER
THE MEASURE ON ORIGIN TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE SENATOR
LABOR IT'S RESOLUTE SENATE
RESOLUTION.
SEVEN BY US SENATOR LABOR.
SO -- WE
ALSO NEED TO THINK BY THE WAY
OUR LEAD COMMITTEE ASSISTANT FOR
HER SERVICE TO THE SENATE --
IN THIS COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS --
JOHNSON TWILL HAS.
MOVED ON TO OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
AND IS NOT WITH US TODAY BUT I
WANT TO ALSO GIVE HER SHOUT OUT
THIS.
AGAIN WITH ALL THE BILLS WE HEAR
THIS IS A VERY TOUGH JOB IN THE
COURSE IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
DOING THE HARD WORK IN THE BACK
ROOM THAT HOPEFULLY MAKE US LOOK
GOOD IF WE DO AND SO I WANTED TO
THANK CHRIS FROM JOHNSON AND
BEST OF LUCK TO YOU AS WELL --
AND I GUESS IT'S THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION WITH THAT --
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND APPROVE THE
RULES OF THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HERE BORDERS RATHER
PORCHES HERE ALLEN.
ALLEN HERE COVER EURO.
CUP HERO HERE MINING HERE
WANTING HERE STERN.
AMBER.
AMBER HERE WHITE HOUSE SKI.
LIKE HOUSE HE HEAR IT A QUORUM
IS PRESENT.
AND OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS TO APPROVE THE COMMITTEE
RULES -- I'D
LIKE TO NOTE.
IN.
RESPECTING THE FACT THAT WE NICE
SEEING THE NON BINARY
DESIGNATION --
AS A GENDER --
HE AND SHE WE ARE NOW MERGING
THEM SO THAT WE ARE YOU USING
WHAT MY CHROMATOGRAM A TEACHER
WOULD HAVE HAD A HEART ATTACK
OVER.
WE ARE USING THE PHRASE THEY IN
REPLACING.
OTHER DESIGNATION SO THAT IT'S A
GENDER NEUTRAL DESIGNATION OF
DAY AND WE'VE DONE THAT THROUGH
MOST OF THE BASICALLY THAT'S THE
PRIMARY.
REFORMS AND REVISIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE RULES SO --
AND I APPRECIATED SENATOR
MORNING OBSERVING --
THAT THE CHAIR IS SHE BUT IN THE
SPIRIT OF GENDER NEUTRALITY FOR
THE RULES OF THIS COMMITTEE IT.
NOW DESIGNATES THE CHAIRS THEY
SO THE WORLD IS A DIFFERENT
PLACE -- MY
GRAMMAR TEACHERS LONG GONE AND I
WON'T BE HEARING FROM HER --
AND IF ANY OF YOU.
FROM.
FROM THE EXACTLY FROM DAY BUT
FOR ANY OF YOU WHO MAY HEAR FROM
AN OLD GRAMMAR TEACHERS.
BLAME IT ON ME.
SO WITH THAT IS OUR MOTION --
BY SENATOR MINING ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE.
THAT I'M A SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
JACKSON HIGH JACKSON I FORGES
[inaudible]
ALAN.
ALAN I COVER HERO.
COVER YOUR I AM MONEY.
MORNING I STERN.
BURKE BY A BIRD I LIKE HUSKY.
WACO SKI I ALL RIGHT --
THAT SIX TWO SIX VOTES AND WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN --
UNTIL THE END OF OUR HEARING AND
WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM THE ONE
BILL -- IS
THAT WE DO HAVE UP TODAY THIS IS.
SENATE RESOLUTION SEVEN BY
SENATOR LABOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
STEP FORWARD.
OF THE GENERAL RULES OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH HELLO
OCCASIONALLY DEVIATE BUT
GENERALLY FOR THOSE NEW MEMBERS
WE HAVE TWO MAIN WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR SUPPORT.
AND THEN SIMILARLY TO MAIN
WITNESSES TWO MINUTE TEACH
MAXIMUM --
FOR OPPOSITION AND AT THAT POINT
USUALLY WE OPENED UP --
FOR QUESTIONS FROM THE DYESS --
THAT RULE FLUCTUATES DEPENDING
UPON THE BILL IN THE ISSUE.
AND SO WITH THAT WE WILL START
GOOD MORNING SENATOR LABOR YOU
ARE OUR FIRST THE BILL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING GOODMORNING MEMBERS I
AM HONORED TO BE THE FIRST BILL
OF THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY BILL CYCLE.
S. R. SEVEN COMMEMORATES THE
FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF ROE
V. WADE THE DECISION WHICH
AFFIRM THAT EVERY WOMAN HAS A
RIGHT TO CONTROL HER OWN
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS.
AND DECIDE FOR HERSELF WIN IF
AND WITH WHOM AND HOW MANY
CHILDREN TO HAVE.
THE ROE V. WADE DECISION HAS
BEEN A CORNERSTONE IN THE
WOMEN'S EQUALITY MOVEMENT AND
IT'S HELPED ADVANCE.
THEIR ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
FULLY IN THE SOCIAL POLITICAL
AND ECONOMIC LIFE OF OUR STATE
AND COUNTRY.
TODAY NATIONAL PEER REVIEWED
STUDIES SHOW THAT ABORTION IS A
SAFE PROCEDURE THAT ONE IN FOUR
WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES WILL
ACCESS.
DESPITE THE SAFETY IN DEMAND FOR
ABORTION SIR BEING OVERTURN
FURTHER A ROAD DUE TO THE FACT
THAT SOME STATES CONTINUE TO
PASS LEGISLATION THAT CREATES
BARRIERS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
FOR WOMEN AND RECENT
APPOINTMENTS TO THE US SUPREME
COURT ARE LIKELY NOT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF WOMEN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE.
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA STANDS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ROE V. WADE AND AS
SUCH SR SEVEN VALIDATES THAT THE
STATE CAN STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS COMMITTED TO PROTECTING AND
ADVANCING ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WHO ALWAYS STRONG
STANDS AND STRONG SUPPORT AND I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT ROE V. WADE
WAS DECIDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE AS I SAID.
RESERVING MINUTES ASSIGNED IT
DAWNED ON ME THAT WHEN I WAS
BORN A WOMAN DID NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE SO IT WASN'T
UNTIL I WAS OLDER THAN A WOMAN
EXCESS THAT RIGHT.
WITHOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS --
MY NAME'S ANDREA SAN MIGUEL AND
THE POLICY ADVOCATE FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
NEARLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PATIENTS THAT WE SERVE ANNUALLY.
JUST WHEN I THINK --
THE AUTHOR SENATOR LEAVE AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE CHANCE
TO HEAR COMMENT --
AGAIN YES NEXT TUESDAY IT'S THE
FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
DECISION THE HISTORIC DECISION
ROE V. WADE --
I JUST WANT TO REMARK THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH
CONSISTENTLY TELLS US.
THAT CONTROL OF ONE'S OWN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AN ACCESS TO
FAMILY PLANNING INCLUDING ACCESS
TO ABORTION.
IS CRITICAL FOR ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL WELL BEING AND MOBILITY.
YET IN THE FORTY SIX YEARS IN AN
EFFORT TO REPEAL THIS RIGHT. FOR
PEOPLE TO CONTROL THEIR OWN
BODIES AND THE RATES AND ACCESS
HAVE IN FACT BEEN ERODED.
IT'S BEEN FORTY SIX YEARS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT NOT JUST
FOR ACCESS TO THE HEALTHCARE
SERVICES.
BUT ALSO FOR THE REVIEW A
DECISION ITSELF.
AND THE THREAT TODAY IS VERY
REAL -- AS
AS WAS REMARKED SO IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA TODAY.
TIME TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THIS FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
ESPECIALLY WHEN PROVIDERS OF
SUCH AS PLANNED PARENT HEALTH
CENTERS.
ARE UNDER SERIOUS AN UNRELENTING
ATTACK SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'M HEARING THIS
AS YOUR FIRST ITEM OF THE YEAR.
WE WE DRIVE OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE HERO THAT.
MEMBERS.
OF THE THIRD ARE PRESENT IN THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CAL AND
SHOULDER SHOULDER WITH CENTER
LEIVA AND OUR COLLEAGUES AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION --
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD STATED THIS IS A
REALLY TOUGH TIME IN THE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE MOVEMENT
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE WAY --
BOTH BY TAKING A STAND TODAY
WITH THIS RESOLUTION IN
ADVANCING OUR OWN POLICIES IN
THE YEAR AHEAD SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
LEIVA AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
YEAR TO CONTINUE TO STAND STRONG
IN SUPPORT OF THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE WAS NO TIME THE OPPOSITION
FILED BUT IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. TWO MINUTES
EACH.
NOW I WANTED THE ISSUE AN
ADMONITION.
WE HAVE RULES IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND IF THERE IS OPPOSITION TO IT
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE PRESENTED
IN A TIMELY FASHION --
I WILL GIVE YOU THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY BUT GOING FORWARD
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE HAVE A
HEAVY CALENDAR.
THERE WILL BE OPPOSITION IT HAS
TO BE.
OF EXPRESSED WITHIN THE CONFINES
OF THE RULES OF THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT GO AHEAD YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TODAY COULD GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU WE CAN ALL PREDICT THE
OUTCOME OF THIS FIRST LOOK GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE WHEN IT SELLS DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE WE CAN ALL
PREDICT THE OUTCOME OF THIS VOTE
SOME WOULD SAY WOULD BE A WASTE
OF MY TIME TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY.
IN I BELIEVE THERE'S ALWAYS
MERIT IN SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER.
YOU HAVE THE POWER.
AND WE ALL KNOW.
IN THE U. S. SIXTY MILLION LIVES
HAVE BEEN KILLED BY ABORTION.
SIXTY MILLION HUMAN LIVES CAN BE
REPRESENTED BY THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO CURRENTLY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA WASHINGTON OREGON
NEVADA AND ARIZONA.
ABORTION IS A BRUTAL BLOODY
BARBARIC AND INHUMANE.
THE MILLIONS OF WOMEN FOR A
LIFETIME LEAVING MANY OF US TO
SUFFER FROM DEPRESSION ANXIETY
PANIC ATTACKS NIGHTMARES.
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ADDICTIONS AND
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE.
ESPECIALLY WOMEN MY AGE WHO WERE
LIED TO BY THE ABORTION INDUSTRY
TELLING US IT WAS JUST A CLUMP
OF CELLS.
YEAH WE KNOW THE TRUTH EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM HAS HEARD THE
BABY'S HEARTBEAT ON AN
ULTRASOUND HAS SEEN THE ARMS AND
LEGS.
HAS SEEN.
THE FACE UNDENIABLY HUMAN.
SR SEVENTY VALUES HUMAN LIFE IT
IS A CIVIL RIGHTS AND JUSTICE
IT'S DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR FAMOUSLY SAID.
INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A THREAT
TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
WHATEVER AFFECTS ONE DIRECTLY.
AFFECTS ALL OF US INDIRECTLY.
KILLING THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US THE WEEK THE VOICELESS
THEM PERFECT ENDING AND WANTED.
IS A LETHAL HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION.
ALL OF THIS BABY GIRLS ARE BEING
KILLED JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE
FEMALE. 90% OF BABIES IDENTIFIED
AS HAVING DOWN SYNDROME ARE
KILLED.
POOR BABIES AND BABIES OF COLOR
BEING KILLED AT DISPROPORTIONATE
RATES.
WE DON'T SOLVE POVERTY BY PORT.
I INVITE YOU TO SPEND SOME TIME
WITH ME AT THE SIDEWALK IN FRONT
OF THESE ABORTION BUSINESSES.
MOST WOMEN I MEET FEEL THAT THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE.
TOMORROW TWENTY BABIES WILL BE
KILLED AT THE FOR PROFIT FAMILY
PLANNING ASSOCIATES HERE IN CAL
AND SACRAMENTO.
ALL BE THERE IN THE RAIN IN THE
WIND.
WITH A SIGN THAT SAYS PREGNANT
NEED HELP WITH THE HEART WILLING
TO DO ANYTHING TO HELP THESE
WOMEN AND TO SAVE LIVES.
WOMEN COMING OUT AFTERWARDS ARE
CHANGED FOREVER.
OFTEN IN SO MUCH PAIN THEY CAN
BARELY.
GET TO THEIR CARS SOMETIMES
BLEEDING THROUGH THEIR PANTS AS
THEY PASSED BLOOD CLOTS LARGER
THAN THE SIZE OF LEMONS.
OR FALL TO THEIR KNEES THEY KEEP.
GIVING YOU A LITTLE EXTRA TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS --
MY NAME IS GREG BURKSWITH.
WOULD YOU MOVE THE MIKE FOALE
ACROSS.
MY NAME'S --
GREG BIRCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL.
AND ON HERE --
TO ALSO TO POSE A THREAT
CONTINUE READING HER SPEECH
BECAUSE IT WAS SO WELL WRITTEN
AND I WAS SENT TO THIS MORNING I
WAS SO IMPRESSED SO.
I'LL KEEP GOING HERE.
I HAVE A DREAM WHEN WOMEN CAN
SUCCEED WITH THAT WITHOUT HAVING
TO KILL THEIR CHILDREN.
I HAVE A DREAM WHERE WE CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WOMEN HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED ONES FACING
CHALLENGES OF AN UNEXPECTED
PREGNANCY. FOR THAT BOY ABORTION
BECOMES UNTHINKABLE.
I INVITE YOU TO SHARE THAT DREAM
pOF CALIFORNIANS TO REJECT
ABORTION.
ABORTION RATE IN CALIFORNIA IS
AT A HISTORIC LOW WITH A 48%
DECLINE IN CALIFORNIA ABORTION
RATES SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE COME BE ON A
POSITIVE LOVING LIFE AFFIRMING
PRO LIFE PRO WOMAN PRO SCIENCE
SIDE OF HISTORY.
YES I KNOW YOU'RE VOTING RECORD
YES I KNOW YOUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LEGIONS TO THE ABORTION INDUSTRY.
YET IN LOVE AND CHARITY I HOPE
THAT SOME DAY EACH OF YOU WILL
HAVE A CHANGE OF HEART.
JUST LIKE JEAN ROW OF ROE VERSUS
WADE HER REAL NAME IS NORMA
MCCORVEY WHO ACTUALLY NEVER HAD
AN ABORTION AND LATER HAD A
COMPLETE CHANGE OF HEART
BECOMING A PRO LIFE LEADER.
LATER IN LIFE ALONGSIDE FORMER
ABORTIONISTS IN NY RLPH FOUNDER
DR BERNARD NATHANSON WHO HAD
DONE OVER AT SIXTY THOUSAND
ABORTIONS IN HIS LIFETIME.
BUT LATER BECAME A PRO LIFE.
IN PRODUCER OF THE SILENT SCREEN.
THERE IS HOPE AND FORGIVENESS
FOR MERCY.
IN CLOSING.
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
SAID THAT OUR LIVES BEGIN TO END
THE DAY WE BECOME SILENT ABOUT
THE THINGS THAT MATTER.
TODAY DESPITE THE POWERS AGAINST
ME I WILL NOT BE SILENT ABOUT
THE MATTER OF ABORTION WHICH
DOCTOR BERNARD NATHANSON CALLED
THE MOST ATROCIOUS WHOLE COST IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED TATES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FOR WITH
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WE WILL
BRING THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENT TO I WILL START --
AND I WILL TELL YOU I'M HONORED
AND PROUD TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION.
THE RIGHT OF WOMEN TO CONTROL
OUR REPRODUCTION.
IS ABOUT.
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT I CAN
THINK OF THAT WOMEN HAVE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE I WAS.
AN ADULT AT THAT POINT IN TIME I
HAD SEEN FRIENDS OF MINE.
GO DOWN TO MEXICO BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT HAVE LEGAL ABORTIONS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
COMING BACK.
SOME OF THEM --
IS SEVERELY DAMAGED BY THESE.
PROCEDURES.
AND YET DESPERATE TO BE ABLE TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES AS THEY CHOSE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT THERE IS A
STRONG --
ELEMENT THAT DOESN'T BELIEVE
THAT WOMEN SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT CHOICE.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT IS AMONG
OUR MOST FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
IT'S BECOME THE SENATE TRADITION
TO MARK THIS ANNUAL EVENT.
IS WELL WE SHOULD AS IT IS
ROOTED IN OUR NATION'S
CONSTITUTION THAT A WOMAN HAS A
RIGHT TO CONTROL HER OWN BODY
AND MAKE HER OWN CHOICES.
AND IN CONSULTATION WITH HER
FAMILY OR HER WHOM EVER SHE
CHOOSES.
YOU REFERENCE THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
I GREW UP IN A REPUBLICAN
HOUSEHOLD BACK IN THE AREA OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
NELSON ROCKEFELLER WAS ONE OF MY
HEROES GROWING UP.
AND I REMEMBER MY PARENTS SAYING
WHAT POSSIBLE RIGHT IS IT OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO TELL A WOMAN WHAT
SHE SHOULD DO WITH HER BODY.
AND I THINK THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE THAT HAS SURE
HOPEFULLY.
SHOULD SURVIVE TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY NOTION THAT GOVERNMENT
SHOULD NOT BE INTERFERING IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES ANYMORE THAN
NECESSARY.
AND CERTAINLY TO INTERFERE IN
THAT MOST BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT.
OF WHEN WITH WHOM AND WHETHER TO
HAVE A FAMILY.
IS AMONG THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE.
SO THIS IS A QUESTION OF
EQUALITY FOR MANY OF US.
BY -- TAKE
UMBRAGE IN SOME OF THE
CHARACTERIZATIONS BUT THIS IS A
BATTLE WE'VE BEEN HAVING FOR
DECADES AND I'M NOT GOING.
TO GET DOWN IN THE MUD ON IT
AGAIN -- THE
TWO USED MARTIN LUTHER KING AS
YOUR REFERENCE I THINK --
THIS MARCHES HIS GOOD REPUTATION
AND THE THINGS THAT HE STOOD FOR
WHICH WERE EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL --
BUT IT IS DEEPLY IRONIC THAT
THOSE WHO CONDEMN DEMOCRATS FOR
SUPPORTING THIS --
CLAIMING THAT THIS IS.
A VALUE OUT OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT
IT IS TOTALLY CONTRARY. TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES AT LEAST
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY I GREW
UP IN.
BUT THIS ISN'T A PARTY ISSUE
THIS IS A HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE.
THIS IS A WOMEN'S RIGHTS ISSUE.
AND WITH THAT --
I WILL.
ENTERTAIN ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR MOTION AND THEN WE
WILL HAVE YOU CLOSE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SENATOR CUMBIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS I'M OBVIOUSLY.
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS I'M A CO
AUTHOR AND I'M PROUD TO BE CO
AUTHOR I THINK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY THIS IS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS ARE ALL ABOUT --
THE ABILITY TO DISAGREE ON ON
ISSUES OUT AND I WANT THE PRE
SHEET THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE --
MY MOTHER WAS A NURSE AND SHE
WORKED IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
AND I WAS BORN INTO A FAMILY OF
DEMOCRATS THAT.
GO BLUE A LONG WAIT BUT MY
MOTHER WAS VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
SHE'D SEEN ON AND THE KIND OF OF
CARNAGE SHE HAD SEEN WOMEN THAT
FELT LIKE THEY HAD NO CHOICE.
AND AND SHE INSTILL THOSE VALUES
IN ME.
AND I FEEL.
LIKE THERE'S NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT IS THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE HOW BIG YOUR FAMILY
SHOULD BE IN AND WHO YOU WANT TO
HAVE CHILDREN WITH.
AND PROTECTING THAT RIGHT IS IS
REALLY A MANAGER THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS IS
OUR MOTION.
DID YOU WANT TO I'M SORRY
SENATOR AWFUL SO THE MOVE BY
SENATOR UMBERG.
SENATOR LABOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
THERE MANY THINGS I COULD SAY IN
RESPONSE BUT I THINK THE ONLY
THING THAT I WANT TO CLARIFY IS
THAT MOST OF US KNOW THERE IS NO
ABORTION INDUSTRY.
IT IS PART OF REPRODUCTIVE CARE
AND YOU CANNOT DIAL 1-800- AND
FIND SOME PLACE TO GO AND HAVE
AN ABORTION SO I JUST ALWAYS
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CLARIFY THAT.
AND I WOULD ALSO JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT THIS IS ABOUT A WOMAN'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CHOOSE I'VE
NEVER KNOWN ANY WOMAN WHO'S HAD
AN ABORTION WHO SKIPPED INTO THE
CLINIC AND WAS EXCITED.
IT WAS A HARD DECISION BUT IS A
DECISION SHE HAD TO MAKE AND WAS
USUALLY CONFRONTED WITH PEOPLE
OUTSIDE WHO MADE HER FEEL EVEN
WORSE.
SO MADAM CHAIR I THINK YOU CAN
FOR YOUR COMMENTS CHAIR MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL DEBATE
HAVING CONCLUDED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
I'M SORRY THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AND WITH
THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENT BY FAX AND I AM FORGES GO.
TO ALLEN.
ALLEN I COVER EURO.
COVER EURO I WANTING.
MONEY I STERN.
NUMBER FIVE NUMBER FIVE WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI MICHAEL SKI I WRITE
THAT -- VOTE
IS. SIX TO WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR JUST A COUPLE MINUTES
IN CASE SENATOR STERN IS ABLE TO
ARRIVE.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT OUR BUSINESS
WILL HAVE BEEN CONCLUDED THANK
YOU SENATOR LABOR THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING HERE.
YOU START COMING ALL RIGHT.
APPARENTLY CENTERS THERE WILL
NOT BE COMING WE WILL CLOSE
CLOSE THE ROLE I SIX HER NOSE
ZERO THE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
AND WE ARE ADJOURNED